most of society's rules and traditions  are based on when people were dying at  50 years old most of the rules of when  you should get married and what you  should do and what you should have  accomplished is literally based on the  last century's dna you are so young you  have  every opportunity technology is  exploding at a speed where your life can  change in a minute on a decision  and literally literally the only thing  that is [ __ ] you up is you worry  about what other people think about your  life whether that's your parents  your friends  me  please stop doing that wear crazy rose  suits  i like it it's very nice  do random [ __ ] try new things  you have your whole life in front of you  i couldn't be happier for you if you're  standing right now you have a hundred  years to live that's actually how it's  going to work out for you and you need  to start acting like it  [Music]  you